[Music]
let's brow ladies and gentlemen here
they are the H
dra the fun
boy the sensitive
one the
leader and the
baby give it up for
froo she
go on the FL let do this no more talking
[Music]
the energy sh when
weow
[Music]
mind
okay great it's working yes come on
guys what's he doing this isn't my
[Music]
Coro
got
[Music]
you ladies and Gentlemen please stand by
uh we're experiencing uh some stuff hey
at least we didn't
fall we fell see what happens when you
don't follow my lead dude that is
exactly what happens when we follow your
lead I don't need this I'm out I'm done
I'm sorry I'm gonna go hike the
neverglade trail by myself bro loan yeah
that's right bro bro going solo YOLO
goodbye
forever fine I'm out of here same here
guys please come
on it's my fault I ruined everything no
no no Branch this is not your fault
we're not in sync we've gone from Boys
to Men and now there's only one
direction for us to go the back streets
get up there go sing with your brothers
I'll do it to save Floyd when I have to
but I'm not doing it right now just for
funsies oh yeah okay you're probably
right no no no no no no you're the one
who wait what' you say no you're afraid
that singing with your brothers again
after all these years will overwhelm you
with emotions too powerful for you to
handle I I agree with you I don't think
you can handle it so I think you
shouldn't do it I think I can handle
singing a song prove it prove it prove
it pro all right fine but this is more
than likely beneath
me W my girl's like candy a candy treat
she knocks me right up off my feet she's
so fine as can be it's like
[Music]
Harmony
baby love the way you turn me
on you got the right
stuff
baby the reason why I sing this
song I can't believe this is really
[Music]
happening
Stay Stay City breaking everybody stay
stay
again I can't believe I remembered every
word and every step looks like your
bandaid aren't behind
you who goes
there
Who Dares trespass on these sacred
grounds France what are you
doing listen we don't want any clown
related trouble okay we're just here
looking for our brother
Clay wait a
second you're trolls so what you're a
clown
[Music]
oh
oh my gosh
hello my name is Viva it is so fantastic
amazing to see other
trolls hi so fantastic amazing is my own
personal word it means um fantastic and
amazing I used to say Astic but then I
was like that's not as good fantas
awesome that's different but that works
too wait a make it your own is this how
people feel when they meet me yes am I
being a lot sometimes I can be a lot I'm
not sure where in the the right place of
course you're in the right place any
troll is welcome here with us okay p p
trolls lights on for our new
[Music]
friends wow oh my gosh are you guys
hungry are you thirsty yes fries fries
you guys want fries I am seeing fries
Bring Out The Works milkshakes to
celebrate woo that's better now I
finally have some energy did you just
braid my hair you're welcome it looks so
[Music]
good oh
yeah keep
it keep
[Music]
it
everyone can't see we're together as
[Music]
walk found
oh boy that was a crazy bachelor party
uh Cloud guy don't feel so
[Music]
good y looking sick kingi you could say
that
again stretch my nails baby how you
feeling I do my hair stretch my nails
baby how you feeling good as
hell it's me he's looking for I can see
it in his eyes now let's get this dress
right uh
no uh-uh no
[Music]
next F Chenille fashion
emergency look at you tiny diamond you
make the cutest Little Flower Boy come
on Daddy I'm not a baby anymore I'm the
cutest Little Flower man but tiny you're
only a month old get everybody treat me
like I'm just a little baby I'm walking
and a the day I'm rolling dice drinking
cof getting wild Daddy I'm a man now not
a little child come on guys it's
[Music]
time get up
everybody get up get up get up we
are I got all my S with
me we
are
[Music]
every hey tiny you see that
button uh yeah that beautiful shiny
button Oh you mean the button that's
taking every five of my being not
depressed yeah I see it press it oh
hecky
yeah
[Music]
let's
yeah the hle every day I'm hust the
hustle uh
[Music]
uh- wow too much hustle is a thing huh
look at
that we are going to make boy band
history tonight bro you're making baby
Branch nervous I feel like I'm going to
barf and pass out and pee your pants all
at once how' you know give it up
[Applause]
[Music]
bro you suck my exquisitely chiseled
rockard abs and I quit Branch we're out
of sink we've gone from Boys to Men and
now there's only one direction for us to
go the back streets bye see you
later Branch what oh hey are you all
right you're smiling and crying at the
same time it kind of looks like it's
hurting your face it does hurt my
face oh baby Branch I'm John Dory
Branch's brother what ow former brother
drama cor me
Dingle it's hard to say I'm sry a
brother is a friend who can never leave
you it's the strongest bond in the world
I would kill to have a sibling to sing
with check out your old outfits puffy
jacket pcell necklaces denim tuxedo did
you have frosted tips look at you you
are so cute I love it it was an ERA
tragic bran our brother is being held
captive in a diamond prison there's only
one thing that's powerful enough to
shatter Diamond the perfect family
Harmony should we be letting a baby
drive I have procured my learner's
permit it was a dty McMahon face the
better question is are you a
narc who comes there we're here looking
for our
[Music]
brother oh my gosh
hello my name is via it is so fantastic
amazing to see other
TRS did you just braid my hair you're
welcome it looks so good I love it is
your dad King Peppe uh yeah poppy I'm
your sister my what w hey man am I the
only one without a long lost sibling
this is your second chance with your
brothers
branch
b b maybe a smaller diaper if this
diaper was any smaller I could taste it
I know you think it's risky and maybe it
is but it'll be worth it family's always
worth it you're I ever I can't believe
this is really
[Music]
happening we still got it looks like
your bandaid aren't behind
you just let me take you to a better
place yeah I'm going to make it kiss the
sky
[Laughter]
[Music]
tonight